another vapor this must have been before
smartphones where you found a way of
trolling someone do you know I'm talking
about I yeah yeah it's kind of trolling
so I like it so I had a really horrible
ex-boyfriend
he was so nasty and I got my first
record deal and I you died at the
beginning you never know like Andrew
you've expressed this stuff you never
know how long it's gonna last
yes because you might you know like you
eat as much you can when they take you
for dinner
except yeah so I got my record deal and
they said so we've we've got three
billboards for your album and you can
choose one of the locations so I had
this bill will put up at the end of this
ex's street every day for months he had
to like go there and be like
[Applause]
we saw definitely and if you didn't see
it friends pointed it out you talking
about smartphones and and the age there
just to go back to the hot briefs for a
second Twitter obviously went mad for
the hot priest and it was one scene
better than Neil scene but it was a gas
over there so crazy I don't really know
I don't really
yeah I think it's quite strange because
the the it was just on Phoebe that scene
yeah you know the camera was just on her
date you actually never see the priest
in that scene so I did think that
there's a touch of the old you know
transgressive everything yes so yeah I
think just the priest thing does it for
people I don't know I don't get it yeah
bit of confession yeah you got it licked
that's all just a couple of tweets these
are mildly streets between 7 hours and
15 days and I'm still thinking about hot
priest and fleabag I was at the Catholic
Church for a wedding today and honestly
it was too soon
this this woman went to a lot of trouble
for this one maybe they should be so
happy with herself so real life heart
priest today they do exist and it does
actually look a bit like it looks like a
vegan sub salad I see I know bring a
leather jacket right in front of you
language this last woman she really went
for he wore a bridge appreciate to it
keep let's use to [ __ ] hell without
preset near my vagina exploded never
quite being able to achieve
[Applause]
[Music]
you